sperm whales spend most of their days
diving far underwater where they hunt
for squid they surface every 45 minutes
or so to breathe and bask and decide
but not all sperm whales plunge into the
deal newborn calves lack the endurance
to make these epic dives and must wait
near the surface for their mothers to
return to them
this cap lols in a gentle sea as his
mother descends a quarter of a mile as
she soars through the darkness and
searches undersea canyons far below him
in pursuit of squid he can still hear
her familiar sonar clicks
fearless and playful the lone baby whale
turns in spins
exploring the dexterity of his great
body in the weightless freedom of
oceanic space
he is covered with remoras harmless
companions who cling to him for a
spectacular free ride when he learns to
dive they will probably leave him unable
to stand the cold and pressure of the
abyss
the baby whale here's his mother
returning
reunited they swim away through the vast
blue waters